our continuing series American Voices
this morning explores the state of Ohio
we are examining how national issues are
playing out in state and local
governments Ohio's Republican Governor
John Kasich ran for president in 2016
during the Trump presidency he has
emerged as a leading voice calling for
unity in politics
Kasich joined with governor's on both
sides of the aisle looking for
bipartisan solutions on issues like
health care and immigration Governor
Kasich welcome back I want to start with
a shooting in Las Vegas but especially
about the how its renewed calls again
for gun control now you have voted in
the past for a ban on assault weapons
surely that hasn't changed in light of
this latest shooting what are you
thinking today well girl I mean if you
really want to get something done the
way to do it is you've got to get the
people who are the strong gun advocates
the people who are not just gonna you
know don't want to listen and those who
favor gun control who are not going to
be extreme and from the standpoint of
saying my way or no way
you got to get them law enforcement and
experts in a room and you got to say
okay we got to let some pressure out of
the pressure cooker we can't just ignore
things so is it this is this bump
business where you can take a gun and
make it make it automatically I'll tell
you what people tell me who understand
this they say you can take all the
devices away we still know how we still
know how to make it sort of automatic
what I believe has to happen is people
of goodwill have to sit in a room and
hammer something out because my mother
used to cook potatoes in this device and
it would whistle and I said mom what is
that she said Johnny that's called a
pressure cooker and if you don't let the
pressure out the thing will blow up but
governor whenever something like this
happens you try to bring the topic up
not you specifically a generic you
everybody says now is not the time to
discuss it now is not the time to play
we have to discuss it I mean you let a
few days go and then you get into it you
know Gail I dealt with the issue of race
in Ohio and I brought people who were
community activists liberals into a room
minorities along with law enforcement
and because they were of goodwill they
hammered out some of the most
comprehensive change in the way the
police and community work if you can do
it with race right which is explosive
and volatile why can't you do it with
guns what makes you think it hasn't been
done with
that somebody hasn't tried we had what
happened in Newtown and children were
dead and you think they'd last people
will get together in a room that care
nobody put him in a room no one called
him into a room Charlie it's like the
Senate it's the United States most
deliberative body yeah but I'm talking
who's giving you the honest answer to
this if I were president what I would do
is I would put these folks in the room
and I'd find out who those people are
who are reasonable when I talk to people
who work with the Highway Patrol there
they have their big gun advocates when I
say is there a way to figure something
out to relieve the pressure they always
say yes so you but you haven't you can't
find people who say no way no how and
you can't find people on the other side
who say we're gonna take away all the
guns so that's how you do it I mean
that's the best chance of doing it and
if you don't do it that way it remains a
steal okay so just to be specific
would you support outlawing these bump
stops oh yeah okay course I mean you can
you would you take action in your state
to outlaw them I don't know if I can
pass it I don't know okay and I don't I
don't know exactly what everything is in
Ohio political will on the line to do it
yeah of course I mean this is makes a
lot of sense to get rid of this nobody
wants that and I think but we have to do
it not in an atmosphere where we're just
operating one side there has to be some
common agreement that we're not after
taking away people's second Amendment
rights if you don't do it together
I don't think it gets to the second
Amendment rights they keep saying that
but second Amendment rights they were
talking about muskets you know the times
have changed so drastically you know we
can have all the philosophize that we
want on the show I want to get something
done I'm telling you the best path and
I'm not telling you that it's there's a
guarantee but with the right leadership
you can get it it's like health care
yeah you know look we if in Washington
right now many of the Republicans do not
want to do anything to fix the healthy
resident the United States Donald Trump
has the political will to do this is he
preparing to bring I don't know bring
the people the room but that's the
question is it not well I I don't know
the leader of the country let me ask you
do you think he does I think he had know
him better and I do probably I mean come
on I don't know I would like to think he
would do that and I'm not sure where he
even is on the issue you remember he
said something about
well we'll have to look at all this and
then right away people started ok let me
ask you this was this this incident in
Las Vegas so different because it is the
largest mass killing in the history of
this country that it might be the
precipitation but yes oh yes but but
what I'm saying is Charlie it has to be
both sides
Winston no but what this is the most
important thing so here's my if people
think all of a sudden they're going to
come take my gun then they're going to
go like crazy and it's not the NRA as
much as the membership the gun owners
across America and these are people who
are Republican Democrat liberal
conservative so they have to understand
we're not out for some wholesale kind of
of disarming what we're talking about
here is some common-sense things for
example should we have armor-piercing
bullets you know I mean that's the
question what do you do about ammunition
I mean these are things that have to be
talked about of people of your party the
Republican Party in Congress recently
had a bill that passed out of committee
was up for vote that would allow
armor-piercing bullets and silencers so
there would be a further devolution of
yeah the silencers are not like it's
silent though I mean look I'm not an
expert in all this but this just lowers
the the volume of the sound but now Ryan
has said we're gonna take a pause now
look what else I want to tell you this
morning is I don't want to see these
health care exchanges fall apart because
it's gonna mean that millions of
Americans are going to lose health
insurance now we have Lamar Alexander
and patty Murray supposedly working on
something down there and I've talked to
senators of both parties and I've said
there is a way to give States
flexibility which is what Republicans
want and Democrats what they need in
terms of wanting to to reimburse Bhama
care but if we don't save these
exchanges if we don't figure out a way
to stabilize this they're going to
collapse now we got to get about this
but right now there's no agreement I am
begging the Democrats to say we want to
have a compromise and I'm I'm trying to
tell the Republicans we need to have one
sounds like you need to be in Washington
governor oh I break into a cold sweat
when everybody's down there okay but I
gotta tell you one thing I love John
McCain that is a iconic amazing man yeah
a lot of people yes
Yeah right for self yeah you always a
good conversation your case is great to
be with all thank you we appreciate it